fast cars are Matias Mueller's passion
whenever Porsche enters a car in a race
there's a good chance he'll be there
whether it's at the 24 Hours of LeMans
here with a hybrid car at the
Nurburgring and Miller loves to win but
now that he's been named Volkswagens new
CEO he's unlikely to be putting in many
appearances at the track
that's because Miller is assuming
control of a car company in crisis he's
been with Volkswagen for close to four
decades working his way up from
apprentice all the way to CEO will the
top job be his crowning achievement or
is he sitting in the ejector seat
personally I will do everything I can to
win back the trust of our clients and
employees our partners investors and the
general public Miller says he wants to
get to the bottom of the
emissions-cheating scandal and polish
VW's tarnished image but that won't be
easy
it will mean recalling at least 11
million vehicles worldwide and modifying
them so that they need to appropriate
emission standards still industry expert
Stephan Barratt still thinks Miller is
the right man for the job
the office is hot you see the
Supervisory Board must have been sure
about him men certainly must have
checked whether mr. Miller was in any
way involved in his affair and he
appears not to be often is when that's
find a nice to sign air above all he has
the experience necessary to reposition
Volkswagen he knows the company and its
shortcomings - the scandal has also
revealed serious problems in VW s
management culture under former CEO
Martin Winterkorn all important
decisions were made involves forg with
its entrenched hierarchy
that something Miller needs to change as
he takes the wheel it's Connie sign
that's yeah I know cool tour there
honest there must be a culture of fear
in which no one dares to inform their
superiors about potential problems they
also need to discuss whether the
pressure to win back market share in the
US was simply too great mocked entirely
in the newest obvious wiser to give in
and do diesel cars have a future in the
u.s. here a Volkswagen group faces fines
and lawsuits amounting to billions of
dollars around half a million of the
affected cars were sold in the US
including ones from premium brand OD
even before the scandal broke Volkswagen
sales were falling in July US sales of
VW's were down two percent compared to
the previous year in Russia sales had
fallen by more than 44 percent and in
China car sales dropped by close to 8
percent the Chinese market is extremely
important for Volkswagen accounting for
one-third of its sales so if that market
has a problem then VW has an even bigger
one and they know that you'll need to
watch that market very carefully and
then quickly take measures to react
that's another task for mr. micawber
dirham moolah album get in the long run
Muller will have to get Volkswagen fit
to build the cars of tomorrow production
costs for its core brand VW are too high
yet half the vehicles it makes are VW's
low profit margins are common in the
auto industry Toyota makes over 1600
euros from each vehicle it sells Skoda
over 1000 GM's profit is just under 800
euros and Ford's above 600 Volkswagens
is lowest at over 500 euros per car
they'll have to introduce more electric
cars into their vehicle fleet that's a
big project and last but not least
Volkswagen must transform itself from a
maker of hardware into a mobility
services provider a veer the concepts of
connectivity and autonomous driving will
play an important role
Matthias Miller has lots of work ahead
to clean up March inventor corns dirty
diesel legacy